jim c'est à vous on va parler de
l'émission de françois bayrou qui était
hier sur le plateau de des paroles et
des actes sur france 2 alors il a répété
qu'il ne voulait pas d'une
présidentielle l'opposant à nouveau
françois hollande nicolas sarkozy marine
le pen qu'il était prêt à faire face à
ces impasses ce sont ses mots et à feu
voilà et donc peut-être se présenter en
est ce qu'un responsable politique qui a
été candidat trois fois déjà à la
présidentielle peut incarner une
candidature de renouveau peut incarner
une candidature d'alternative selon-vous
marielle de sarnez
on peut reprendre la question peut-être
au début ça vous échappe pas que nous
sommes prêts et françois bayrou le
premier à soutenir alain juppé vous avez
saisi ça que c'est d'ailleurs je le note
au passage rare qu'un homme politique de
premier plan
c'est françois bayrou a quand même une
faune la confiance de beaucoup de
français aujourd'hui qu'un homme
politique de premier plan disent qu'il
est prêt à soutenir un autre homme
politique c'est moi je connais pas
d'autres exemples dans la vie politique
française s'est donc je trouve que de ce
point de vue il est intéressant et
pourquoi il est prêt à soutenir alain
juppé ben pour ce que j'ai essayé
d'expliquer tout à l'heure on a besoin
de changer la donne politique dans ce
pays
et donc on a besoin d'avoir un président
rassembleur un président qui apaise qui
porte une vision qui soit à même de
conduire le pays est de conduire au fond
les changements nécessaires pour que les
français pour que les français vivent
mieux
bah oui oui oui c'est bien qu'ils aient
des nouvelles têtes
emmanuel macron il existe et c'est bien
oui mais justement peut-être quelques
fois on a besoin et de nouvelles têtes
et d'expériences et la garantie qu est
ce qui fait qu alain juppé est
plébiscité aujourd'hui dans les sondages
c'est bien sûr les qualités personnelles
qui sont les siennes
mais ça aussi justement son âge
paradoxalement 1 les gens se disent il a
de l'expérience il sera sage et sera
peut-être pas là grand huit est plus là
pour nous c'est peut-être trop j'ai tout
ça c'est intéressant je trouve peut-être
due aussi au rejet de nicolas sarkozy
comme de françois hollande bien sûr vous
voyez bien que nicolas sarkozy françois
hollande
aujourd'hui ce sont les deux
personnalités qui sont le plus au mont
valier
le moins apprécié des français dans les
sondages pour autant qu'on puisse mieux
après ils ont des raisons différents
sarkozy a un noyau dur peut-être
françois hollande un petit noyau je sais
pas s'il sera déchu ou pas l'un c'est
peut-être pour sa politique l'autre
c'est peut-être pour sa personnalité on
peut ensuite continuer longtemps
après ça veut pas dire qu'ils ne seront
pas candidats l'un et l'autre donc ça va
être ça toute la question de l'année qui
va s'ouvrir et qui va venir devant nous
mais au delà de la question des
primaires on y reviendra dessus je pense
que c'est très important moi j'ai
vraiment jeu tout mon engagement d'aller
dans les mois qui vont venir ça sera de
faire en sorte que la présidentielle
prochaine soit vraiment utile que ce
soit pas un mandat de plus à blanc que
ça soit pas un mandat de plus où on est
à chaque fois réglé aucun des problèmes
des français
moi j'ai à dire et j'ai envie de changer
parlons un peu des élections régionales
le modem a choisi la stratégie
d'alliance on l'a dit avec les
républicains sa perle être facile par
tout cela dit on l'a vu en auvergne
rhône-alpes pardon le modem se s'est
divisée un peu sur son soutien à laurent
wauquiez non non notre chef de file
patrick mignola s'est allié avec
l'invention s'est allié avec laurent
wauquiez abbas était pas évident du tout
parce que laurent wauquiez a priori sur
ses positions par exemple européenne ya
eu des interrogations
et ce quand il a donné c'est qu'il a
donnée nature écoutez si vous vous
assemblez rassemblé qu'avec des gens qui
sont exactement les mêmes qui pensent
exactement la même chose que vous vous
n'avez pas forcément de capacité de
rassemblement large il faut des
rassemblements larges il en faudra pour
le pays après la présidentielle et il en
faut aux élections régionales alors ce
rassemblement large vous en faites
partie en ile de france puisque vous
êtes candidate sur les lieux je suis en
dernière position sur la liste gandhi
pour voilà pousser la liste est donc
moyennement soutiennent raison si on
incendie date à être conseillère
régionale c'est ça que je voulais
arrêter kiel en position éligible le ps
a dénoncé cette semaine la présence de
plusieurs proches de la manif pour tous
sur les listes de
huit candidats sont notamment issus de
sens commun c'est le mouvement anti
mariage qui est associé à l'ump
est ce que ça vous pose problème a dit
on ne sait pas ma sensibilité
mais ça ne me pose aucun problème quoi
il faudrait mettre sur une liste que des
gens qui pensent tous pareils qui ont la
même tête que le même physique quand le
même adn
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire il ya dans
cette manière de penser la politique de
la part des socialismes alors je retiens
c'est les campagnes et campagne ça
permet pas tout c'est une espèce de
sectarisme de préjugés comme ça tu que
sont les uns les autres
c'est un délit de penser comme ça qu'on
accole aux uns aux autres mais tout ça
sympa je pense qu'ils perdent leurs
nerfs de ce point de vue là que ça n'est
pas raisonnable de faire ce type de
procès je trouve que valérie pécresse
c'est une très bonne candidate
elle est légitime pour la région et pas
seulement d'aujourd'hui ça fait des
années qu'elle parcourt cette région
elle aime cette région je pense qu'elle
sera une très bonne présidente de région
parce qu'elle a montré dans cette
campagne et elle monte dans cette
campagne une capacité à rassembler une
capacité à ouvrir largement mais
justement bon pour moi
la présidente de région ça doit être
quelqu'un qui s'adressent les anciens et
des franciliens ce qu'elle doit
rassembler jusqu'à nicolas dupont aignan
on sait que il pourrait peut-être
attendre la barre symbolique de 10% qui
lui permet de drapage les franciliens
verrons bien qu'il ya un vote utile au
fond au premier tour et un bulletin qui
est celui du vote utile si on veut le
changement dans la région et pour moi il
faut un changement pour la vie
quotidienne des franciliens dans la
région ces de valérie pécresse
jamais il atteint est ce que les listes
de fait le répète je vienne voiture
lander le vote uniquement moi non mais
c'est une hypothèse que je retiens pas
je pense que les franciliens avec ne se
tromperont pas ils ont pour tous ceux
qui veulent que ça change que ça bouge
qu'on trouve des stages pour ses enfants
et pour ses mômes qu'on trouve de
l'emploi que la région soit au service
des pme
qu'on soit mieux transporter et pas
transporter comme on l'est aujourd'hui
et je pourrais continuer la liste
longuement baiia 1 veut pas du projet
valérie pécresse donc campagne au centre
et à droite campagne au centre campagne
à droite campagne aux déçus de la gauche
campagne à ceux qui se reconnaissent pas
dans le sectarisme du candidat de la
gauche
oui c'est ça la campagne qu'il faut
mener dans les semaines qui viennent une
campagne pour les franciliens